all right three areas that we'll be
talking about uh today uh the activity
to the north around the Oscar River
the back commit region in the donbass
and then the big swathe of activity that
we're seeing in the south
looking at the North in the first
instance and the gains that we've seen
and very impressively from Ukraine and
they've taken a pause at the there's a
line from Lyman here the river system
the Oscar that heads to the north of the
Russian border uh the Ukraine's have
gone firm there the Russians have taken
a tactical bound as it's called a
retreat uh Backs from 25 kilometers
where there is new defensive positions
being put in place
it will take some time for the
ukrainians to work out how to do the
next phase of a phase of attack but that
attack will will come at some point
the back commit region the town here
um
it's very much I still a stalemate not a
lot is happening there Fierce fighting
over not a lot of grounds but to the
South is most interesting
um we see a lot of activity
um from the Curson
the city here the inhulitz river here
I'll draw your attention to and then
where there's been breakthroughs
breakthroughs here and here by the
ukrainians
um
this is something that was not
anticipated to happen there's the
operational silence but it has happened
it's caught the Russians on their back
foot and what we started to see is that
there's been movements of weapons
Munitions and tanks down to reinforce
those positions there and lastly we have
some 5 000 Russian troops here and also
some 20 odd thousand Russian troops here
and that really means that the
ukrainians now have the problem of
potentially having 25 000 prisoners of
water to take care of
elsewhere we're seeing
um discussions of a nuclear train what
does that what does that mean well the
12th directorate it looks after tactical
nuclear capability
and we see a train with a number of
wagons on the back of it which may or
may not belong to 12 directorate uh
exercises such as this are the norm
and we take it seriously because Putin
has said he's not bluffing but I think
what's really important to understand is
that there's no evidence on any of the
battlefields I've just discussed which
suggests that Russian forces are moving
to a footing where a nuclear attack
would take place therefore it's unlikely
that the threat is as serious as serious
as put in the sing